Pengoptimuman klasik adalah langkah penting dalam algoritma kuantum-klasik
seperti variational quantum eigensolver atau pembelajaran mesin kuantum.
Tapi, ia selalunya susah nak meminimumkan
fungsi yang kompleks dalam ruang parameter berdimensi tinggi.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan dalam video ni kita akan terokai
rutin pengoptimuman klasik untuk algoritma kuantum-klasik.
Masalah pengoptimuman memang tak mudah.
Bila bilangan parameter bertambah, begitu juga bilangan kemungkinan
kombinasi nilai, dan ia bertambah secara eksponen.
Dalam catur, contohnya, ada 64 petak
dan setiap pemain ada 16 buah catur — lepas setiap pemain gerakkan satu buah,
ada 400 kedudukan berbeza. Lepas dua langkah, 72,084 kedudukan,
lebih kurang 9 juta lepas tiga langkah dan lebih kurang
280 bilion lepas empat langkah.
Kalau kita sampai 40 langkah je, bilangan kedudukan yang mungkin
dianggarkan sekitar sepuluh kepada kuasa 120.
Nak main dengan sempurna kena terokai semua kedudukan yang mungkin
dan pertumbuhan yang luar biasa ni bermakna nak semak
semua kedudukan satu-satu memang tak boleh buat.
Ni boleh diselesaikan dengan pecahkan masalah kepada dua sub-masalah yang lebih kecil.
Pertama, kita perlu tentukan susunan papan catur mana
yang mungkin akan muncul dalam langkah seterusnya.
Kita panggil ini subruang kepentingan kita.
Kedua, dengan subruang tu, kita kena tentukan langkah terbaik.
Kita panggil ini langkah terbaik kita.
Dalam analogi ni, pencarian awal melalui subruang kepentingan
adalah analog kepada algoritma pengoptimuman klasik kita.
Bila subruang kepentingan tu dah diketahui,
algoritma kuantum biasanya bertanggungjawab mencari langkah terbaik,
berdasarkan subruang tu.
Jom kita mulakan dengan satu parameter je dulu,
theta, yang memparameterkan fungsi kos yang nak kita optimumkan.
Kalau kita plot fungsi tu, katakan ia nampak macam ni,
pada paksi-X kita ada nilai parameter theta
dan pada paksi-y ada fungsi kos.
Ingat, fungsi kos ni boleh jadi kos kewangan sebenar
yang nak kita minimumkan atau macam yang selalu dalam variational quantum
eigensolver, ia boleh jadi tenaga yang diminimumkan oleh alam semula jadi.
Objektif kita adalah nak cari nilai theta
yang sepadan dengan kos paling rendah.
Kita mulakan dengan nilai awal theta dan dalam setiap langkah pengoptimuman
kita cari theta baru yang kurangkan kos lagi.
Nampak macam kita boleh tahu arah mana nak pergi dalam graf kalau kita boleh tengok keseluruhannya.
Tapi kesulitan dalam pengoptimuman adalah kita sebenarnya tak boleh.
Kita hanya tahu nilai kos — sekeping kecil daripada keseluruhan gambar —
sebaik sahaja kita nilai fungsi pada theta yang dipilih.
Inilah cara pengoptimuman berfungsi secara umumnya.
Pengoptimum sampelkan parameter theta dan kira nilai kos.
Macam yang korang boleh bayangkan, memilih parameter theta secara rawak untuk bina semula
keseluruhan topologi fungsi memang tak cekap.
Sebaliknya, apa yang pengoptimum bijak buat ialah mencari
kecerunan fungsi dalam setiap langkah.
Dengan cara ni, pengoptimum tahu arah mana dalam plot
yang perlu diikut untuk cari kos paling rendah.
Bila kecerunan dah sifar, algoritma berhenti,
dan minimum ditemui.
Minimum ni mungkin bukan minimum global.
Ia mungkin minimum tempatan,
iaitu nilai fungsi kos paling rendah dalam kawasan sekitarnya
tapi bukan sepanjang keseluruhan julat theta.
Dalam kes satu parameter, tu memang boleh berlaku.
Tapi, makin banyak parameter yang kita ada,
makin kompleks fungsi tu jadinya.
Dah dalam kes dua parameter, kita ada permukaan,
dan dalam kes empat parameter, kita dah tak boleh lakar pun.
Macam contoh catur tadi, semua kemungkinan
cepat jadi tak boleh diuruskan.
Kita nampak bahawa ia memang susah nak meminimumkan
fungsi yang kompleks dalam ruang parameter berdimensi tinggi.
Walau bagaimanapun, untuk dapat hasil yang baik, kita nak pengoptimuman klasik
yang cepat dan tepat.
Ia juga perlu tahan terhadap hingar,
yang akan beri kesan besar dalam komputer kuantum jangka pendek.
Algoritma pengoptimuman klasik boleh dibahagikan secara kasar
kepada dua kelas — kaedah carian terus dan kaedah berasaskan kecerunan.
Kaedah berasaskan kecerunan memerlukan maklumat tentang kecerunan
fungsi semasa proses pengoptimuman.
Ini boleh dikira secara analitik
atau dianggar dalam pengiraan beza terhingga.
Kaedah carian terus tak guna maklumat kecerunan
dan guna strategi lain untuk meminimumkan fungsi kos.
Antara algoritma pengoptimuman yang paling kerap digunakan
dalam bidang pengkomputeran kuantum adalah pengoptimum berikut.
COBYLA bermaksud constrained optimization by linear approximation
dan ia adalah algoritma pengoptimuman tanpa kecerunan.
SLSQP adalah sequential least squares programming,
algoritma pengoptimuman berasaskan kecerunan.
Ia guna vektor gangguan stokastik
untuk kira anggaran kecerunan fungsi kos secara serentak.
Dalam persekitaran tanpa hingar, pengoptimum macam COBYLA
dan SLSQP didapati menumpu lebih cepat berbanding SPSA.
Pengoptimum klasik ada parameter tersendiri
yang boleh korang tetapkan untuk kes tertentu, contohnya saiz langkah.
Ini biasanya boleh didapati dalam dokumentasi
pengoptimum yang berkenaan.
Saya galakkan korang tengok senarai rujukan di bawah untuk perbandingan
pengoptimum klasik yang paling terkini.
Jom kita terokai satu lagi fenomena yang berkaitan
dengan pengoptimuman klasik circuit kuantum berparameter.
Macam yang kita nampak tadi, kecerunan fungsi kos yang lenyap boleh tunjukkan
bahawa pengoptimum terjebak pada dataran tanpa ciri menarik — yang dikenali sebagai
"barren plateau."
Barren plateau boleh berpunca daripada banyak faktor.
Kecerunan fungsi kos yang sepadan dengan circuit kuantum
dengan parameter yang dimulakan secara rawak
mereput secara eksponen ke sifar mengikut bilangan qubit.
Ini sebab ruang kuantum yang diterokai oleh pengoptimum
menjadi semakin besar secara eksponen bila bilangan qubit bertambah.
Cara untuk tangani masalah ni termasuklah mengurangkan bilangan parameter
dan dengan itu dimensi ruang yang mendasarinya.
Satu lagi cara nak faham asal-usul masalah barren plateau
ialah sifat circuit berparameter yang tak spesifik kepada masalah
yang berhadapan dengan ruang parameter yang sangat besar secara eksponen.
Mereka bentuk circuit mengikut cara yang disesuaikan dengan masalah
yang sedang dipertimbangkan boleh jadi penyelesaian yang baik.
Selain ruang parameter eksponen yang mencetuskan barren plateau,
fenomena fizikal lain juga boleh menjana barren plateau:
hingar dan nyahkoheren yang ada dalam eksperimen pengkomputeran kuantum,
kebolehungkapan keseluruhan circuit berparameter,
atau ketaksetempatan dan darjah keterjeratan fungsi kos yang dimodelkan.
Ia masih jadi bidang kajian yang aktif untuk tangani cabaran-cabaran ni.
Setelah kita semak komponen utama VQE,
kita akan rumuskan algoritma ni dalam video seterusnya.